[Applause]
the security services and intelligence
agencies will come under great pressure
and scrutiny as everyone from the Prime
Minister down watches every move they
must balance the patience needed for a
thorough investigation with an urgency
for answers the very senior officers
that sit within Cobra part of their job
is to deal with the politicians and keep
that pressure away from the operational
officers who are trying to work steadily
towards the answers that everybody needs
Northwest terror command has been
preparing for a terror attack Greater
Manchester Police have repeatedly
trained for such an incident and mi5 has
a base in the region that for whatever
reason this one slipped through if they
are willing to kill children there is no
way you can reason with those
individuals they are too far gone
this isn't about de-radicalization
unfortunately this is about trying to
foil and disrupt them as much as
possible
JTAG the Joint Terrorism analysis center
sits inside mi5 and sets the UK national
threat level it is currently at severe
meaning an attack is likely it is
constantly assessed and for now JTAG has
not raised it to critical the highest
level mi5 in counterterrorism police
were very quick to establish the
identity of the attacker war will be
harder is establishing whether or not he
was part of a network where did he learn
the skills to make a bomb did he travel
to Syria was he getting help to someone
else perhaps make the bomb for him after
the 2015 Paris attacks a state of
emergency was invoked by the French
government
it gives police more powers to take on
terrorism but there won't be a state of
emergency in Britain look the public
doesn't want to live in a police state I
think the public would be tolerant of
more police on the streets but I'm not
sure what more it would provide than
what's already going on as with every
terrorist attack there will be an
internal investigation to work out how
things could have been done better but
that's not for now we're still in the
early hours after the biggest terrorist
attack in Britain for
more than a decade Alistair bunk all Sky
News